there's reason to think that the church
like what does it look like in 20 years
are there church how many churches are
still left right in Germany none in
Germany it's going to be they'll be
either Unitarian or just like I don't
know cellos or something but it's also
self-inflicted because uh I I still
think the pandemic comes along the
church has willingly shut down lots of
people yeah lot of people weren't going
already but many people who were said
well if apparently it's not that
important you can just shut down and
what do I need you for I even some
Christians told me they said Michael the
church is not a place you know it's the
people it's the called out people and
obviously there's a lot of Truth to that
it's also a place it's also a place it's
like a place where you gather more more
than two together and you have
sacraments and stuff and you don't have
the the right and the sacrament of the
purel and the face Mantia and it's
called a church called a church so we
call that